what's going on guys this is Rob and the
god of nightmares conquers reality in
night terrors part four so this picks
back up again with Damian Wayne the Son
of Batman Batman who's possessed by dead
man if you don't know what that means
it's not overly important and then of
course Wesley Dodd Sandman who is very
much entwined with the idea of Dreams
nightmares different things like that
all of this is important because as we
talked about in our previous video they
now have possession of The Nightmare
Stone which is to say the god of
nightmares is very much like Freddy
Krueger in the sense that he only really
exists in people's nightmares and that's
basically it as long as you're awake in
the real world you're basically fine but
in the same way that rattlesnake
anti-venom is derived from rattlesnake
venom the belief is that by using the
nightmare Stone they can basically
overcome the power of the god of
nightmares and so what they end up doing
as they make their way into Arkham
Asylum which according to their best
estimations is where the physical body
of the god of nightmares is currently
residing once they get in there you have
this really interesting moment where
like Batman dead man whatever you want
to call them it's just kind of like okay
so this is obviously some kind of a trap
right like I mean this whole entire city
is encased and just like this really
dark nasty looking ooze type stuff to
reflect the kind of Corruption of the
god of nightmares as it's slowly eeking
its way into the real world but here
inside on this level everything is so
perfectly clean and so that's kind of
their concern because as they make their
way through Arkham Asylum Damian Wayne
momentarily falls asleep now one of the
things you remember is that Damien Wayne
like most everybody else on Earth did
initially succumb to the influence of
the god of nightmares which was
basically putting everybody to sleep
right making him fall asleep and then
essentially keeping them asleep but the
crazy thing about Damian is that due to
a combination of his training from the
League of Assassins as well as his time
with Batman and even his own individual
studies he was basically able to control
his dreams and wake up at out of his own
dream right so he kind of kicked himself
up most people can't do that and in fact
Batman can't even do that which is a
pretty impressive feat when you look at
it on the whole for Damien but as he
falls asleep here Batman kind of turns
around and greets him and he says like
it's me Damien dead man left my body to
go ahead he's gone to battle insomnia by
himself you don't have to keep going we
can go home now father and son finally
together again and that's when Damien's
like you're not my father like he
immediately attacks insomnia now of
course at that moment Damien's woken up
right like he's kind of shaken awake and
the whole thing is revealed to basically
be a nightmare but Damian Wayne
realizing that it like it contrasts
starkly to what actually happens in the
world which is Damien asked what happens
Sandman says you started to fall asleep
when we were going up the stairs and
Batman just says keep an eye on him
Dodds this will all be over soon so
what's really interesting here is that
Damien realized Batman was not his dad
because he was caring because he was
compassionate right that's not Bruce
Wayne despite all of his faults and
Imperfections that's just not who he is
he loves his son but that's just not the
kind of person that he is so I found
that kind of interesting and I felt like
that was something worth paying
particular attention to here because it
really feeds into the nature and the
relationship between Batman and Damian
Wayne but what ends up happening is that
even with Boston bran himself as he
makes his way towards like the actual
door these kind of like apparitions
right manifestations specifically of
Dove who's a long dead superhero in DC
Comics but was at one point the interest
or love interest of dead man manifests
right and it's like what's so wrong with
the idea of insomnia killing everybody
on Earth we would all be able to be
together right you and I would be
together again and that kind of thing
but ultimately dead man is just kind of
like no that's not how things are
supposed to be and we can't let the bad
guy win now there is history there
between uh Boston Brand and dove in the
sense that like yes they were love
interests Boston Brand was actually
jumping from body to body in order order
to have a relationship even a physical
relationship with Dove it was kind of
strange not gonna lie right but it's one
of those weird moments regardless once
they get into the actual room quite
literally it looks like the stuff of
nightmares but we get this really cool
explanation before we get the origin of
the god of nightmares where we're
basically told by dead man that his name
is Christopher Lucas that he was a
killer who refused to sleep so the Press
called him insomnia he was locked up in
Arkham after he said that he saw
something in his dreams that drove him
mad and the doctors here forced him to
stay asleep so it's almost kind of like
a torment it's almost a bit of a torture
now him having the ability to jump in
and out of people's nightmares and force
people to sleep again we talked about
that before that's due to his exposure
from the Lazarus Planet event which is
to say quite literally this giant
volcanic explosion with chemicals from
the Lazarus Pit that normally resurrects
people and in turn it started giving
people Powers with Lucas himself it
granted him the ability to jump in and
out of people's nightmares much like
Freddy Krueger and even put people into
an almost permanent sleep and so what's
so interesting here is that dead man in
possession of The Nightmare Stone leaves
the body of Bruce Wayne and then jumps
into the mind of Christopher Lucas in
order to use the nightmare Stone against
him but we also get the full totality of
his origin and what we end up finding
out here is that Christopher Lucas was
at one point a huge fan of the Justice
League and that makes sense given the
fact that he was in Gotham given the
fact that he is or at least like anybody
on Earth Champions the Justice League as
superheroes and so on and so like even
his son is wearing like a flash shirt
right that kind of thing and so what he
does when he gets in is he tells his
family well you know the Justice League
is downtown fighting a monster and they
said everybody needs to evacuate but I
know the Justice League will save us and
then like the whole place implodes right
it's just like boom like the whole place
crashes in his entire family is killed
and like that's what drove him insane
that's the thing it broke him right
because he wanted the Justice League
come there and save him but ultimately
they didn't and that's when he manifests
as insomnia right the god of nightmares
and it's just like this is what I dream
about right when I close my eyes this is
what I saw this is what drove me insane
in the first place it's why I never
wanted to sleep now what's so
interesting is this whole event right
this massive chaotic moment that was
during the Dark Knights Metal Event
right like that was during the point
when the Justice League were fighting
evil Batman right all those evil
versions of Batman Red Death Batman who
laughs so on and so forth it was cool it
was this really really amazing moment a
really amazing line of Batman stories
but that Calamity is what cost him his
family but something that I would argue
here right somebody that I would argue
here and you probably picked it up sure
blaming the Justice League they're the
reason why all this happened right
they're the reason why his family is
dead and they were never saved all that
kind of stuff this is all rooted in
guilt because they were warned to
evacuate and they didn't they they
stayed and they died right his whole
family died so on some level at the very
core level of all of this it's
Christopher Lucas is who's not angry at
the Justice League he's angry at himself
because he knows he should have gotten
his family out of there he didn't and
you could argue he's the one that got
his family killed so again it's really
interesting in the sense that it's
really just very much unspoken but the
reality here is his hatred for the
Justice League is so extreme that he
wants the world to see the Justice
League the way he sees them he wants the
world to hate the Justice League to
despise the Justice League because
they're not Heroes who save the world
from danger they're Heroes who create
danger now if any of you guys have been
reading DC Comics for really since
Infinite Crisis you've heard this before
that was the stance of Superboy Prime
superheroes are not superheroes anymore
they're anti-heroes the line between the
good guy and the bad guy is incredibly
blurred and that's been an on running
theme in DC Comics for a couple decades
do superheroes save the world from
threats or do superheroes create the
threats that they save the world from
right is that how this works just by
virtue of their actions are they
creating more problems than they're
stopping and so what the god of
nightmare says is he says like yeah I
don't want to kill the Justice League
The Death of my family was my nightmare
so I thought I would return the favor
the little clues that I've shown you
along the way the little bits and pieces
that was all part of a much bigger game
I wanted you to bring the nightmare
Stone here I wanted you to show me this
nightmare said I wanted to see that you
actually have it and what he does is he
says did you forget the rules that were
established when this whole thing kicked
off if you die in your nightmares you
die in real life and in that moment he
seizes the nightmare Stone and even
kills his own physical form and what it
does is it basically allows his
spiritual Essence really the nightmare
version of himself to manifest in the
real world he could have done this at
any point in time but he was waiting on
the arrival of The Nightmare Stone in
order to do do it now that he has it in
his possession everybody starts waking
up right Joker wakes up and Nightwing
wakes up and Flash wakes up all those
guys from those horrible ass tie-in
Comics they all wake up right they all
just start snapping too even Boston bran
is no longer in the body of Batman and
Batman wakes up this is where the end of
the Batman tie-in issues that we covered
this is where that picks up right where
he wakes up and Damien says this is the
real world and we lost right that kind
of thing this is where that happens and
so ultimately in possession of The
Nightmare Stone what the god of
nightmares is able to do is bring all of
his nightmares everybody's nightmares
into the real intangible world this guy
takes over reality if you have seen it
as a nightmare in your dream it will
manifest in the real world it's amazing
of course we do get the evil version of
the Justice League which you would
expect to happen out of that but it's
dope which is cool because finally this
story is starting to get awesome with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end if you need to get caught
up on night terrors make sure you click
this link to the playlist and I will
catch you all later peace